hello uh welcome to on australia's
commentaries today's episode is obi-wan
kenobi that's that's the content this
week yeah um content content because we
love it
who doesn't love content uh we are gonna
talk about our uh thoughts and feelings
about the series although you could what
is that one i don't know this is just in
front of me and it's gone it's dead to
it
gently put it down under here
potentially
important all right i was just gonna
move it off camera folks i'll
i will take it out of uh long's paycheck
how dare you check out the twitch
channel uh yeah oh check out the twitch
channel
uh that's a hard drive oh [ __ ]
i just saw it on camera and was like
there's an object in my path yeah no
this is just holding it we're good
all right it wasn't a heartbeat now we
can focus on what's important obi-wan
kenobi um obi-wan kenobi we're gonna
watch a trailer start and stop when we
have thoughts we're gonna show you some
deleted scenes uh and we will answer
your comments and questions about the
piece of equipment we just destroyed so
keep those coming in the chat and then
uh we will tease you with next week's
honest trailer which we're all very
excited about um this one however well
we were all so excited yeah i was
excited about it i mean i i will um
check out any of these disney plus uh
star wars shows even though they are all
i don't want to say underwhelming or
overwhelming uh we were saying they're
very whelming i've been well i'm totally
i was i was totally welmed by obi-wan
very consistently well yeah
yeah uh i i don't um
i'm not too attached because i'm i think
speaking for myself here i'm not a
prequels fan i don't have him built up
in my mind as uh the character's
supposed to be a certain way or have a
certain standard of dignity
because man he is uh he is living rough
at the beginning of this one and they
just keep piling on and he sucks but i
liked watching him kind of climb out of
the gutter and go through his mid-life
crisis and uh and and kind of clean up
his act i enjoyed it
obviously we can poke a million holes in
a lot of logic things especially uh
riva's
thing
her whole deal yeah uh but um
i really enjoyed he he was the best part
of the prequels for me and he's he's
just a great actor i've just loved him
train spotting and these it's fun to
watch so i was whelmed what about you
danielle yeah i just always i guess i
thought um down on his luck obie becomes
ben was going to be the plot of the show
i don't know what everyone else was
expecting that was like well he didn't
lightsaber enough for like this and that
and like okay i get it but i guess i
always thought that it was going to be
like obi-wan kenobi
just a a sad single man living on the
one planet that matters they could have
mandalorian to him i guess and made him
just like the grizzled caveman who you
don't want to mess with um but that's i
don't know that that could have been fun
too we're just we're at this weird
moment where it's like
do star wars fans not get you know how
drama works like that's how a story he
can't start out as the ultimate badass
because then it's not there's nowhere to
go it's not an interesting progression
it's not a good tv show well i think
that you could you could bounce that
question back to does disney know how
drama works because like
maybe you if a character completes an
arc or a journey you should just move on
to somebody else instead of revisiting
the same three characters and resetting
them i mean i'm not saying i think does
disney know how drama works is a bad
question
i think that's a
fine question let's table that
uh because i do think a lot of these
disney plushies including this one they
do have those kind of structural issues
where it's like this doesn't feel like
it's sufficiently motivating for a pilot
or this doesn't give me enough context
to know where the story's gonna go or on
who this character really is i mean the
drama question is interesting because
there is a template for drama for
especially televised serialized drama
where the character doesn't arc and
that's you know
episodic right if you were going to get
this one
going to do that blaster will travel you
could totally make that work and that i
mean mandalorian especially season one
mandalorian that is basically the
strategy yes it's just it's like bounty
law in space and he just goes around and
does missions and i think that works
great i i think that that definitely
isn't going to work for this kind of
show
mandalorian to me feels like almost the
opposite mission of of this and if the
question is just i i i liked it i like
both i like mandalorian i liked obi-wan
i enjoy both of these shows i hated boba
fett i didn't really like boba fett
because it just i'm gonna get to my back
to tank well because it didn't have
another wound
it's not entertaining it's like
compelling in a weird way
that's the crosstalk that's the funniest
out of context the funniest thing for
that entire show is kids like
we gotta steal water because we can't
afford anything he's like that's a crime
you're a bounty hunter you're not
roberto
anyway
uh danielle do you wish obi-wan was was
just week to week uh him slashing um
tuscan raiders um
i do i am a big sucker for monster of
the week like that is i will put that
out there right there um or like mystery
of the week or whatever it is i this was
one
i i appreciated it in both ways could
have been a movie
right right but i i like that whereas
mandalorian is like let's blow up this
little corner of the world and make it
into a tv show this one is very
purposefully like bridge the gap between
these two trilogies yes more so than any
of the other star wars shows this one is
literally like
let's connect these two things in a way
that ties them together thematically and
like plays into all these things it
brings back these characters that
audiences like i thought it was pretty
successful it was successful in that it
was it was definitely some glue between
the prequels which are basically have up
until this point been completely
unacknowledged outside of clone wars um
to to the modern day so i would like to
see wado in there
we'll we'll get to that there's a
water-shaped hole in this water
blobs missing from this [ __ ] god if they
did a watto series
oh um all right i've been saying i think
it should be uncut gems but with watto
he's got a bunch of big pod race wagers
going he's behind he's got to like make
up all this time and money relentless
anxiety driven like a comedians and cars
thing of like people in pod racers uh
so what do you do
i know a good place turn left up here is
good trust me
let's play the trailer for obi-wan
kenobi
now the george lucas cashed out and
disney turned the franchise into fifa
with lightsabers open wide as they chuck
another hunk of content on the rancor
pit of disney plus
what
this is actually pretty tasty
uh
i really like that they brought back the
like weird uh make your own like
stew from mre yeah yeah little from
dinty moore thing yeah like it's like a
force awakens kind of call back in some
ways like i like that we're now in an
era where
shows can do callbacks to the sequels
like they've established things that are
now far enough back that we could be
like oh right like rey had right oh wow
i like that moment that's nice all right
i'm still thinking about toydarians and
pods drinking jawa juice
i think you've got something nice
[Music]
you had to watch han solo turned into a
broke divorced dad you had to watch luke
skywalker become a gross recluse
now it's obi-wan kenobi's turn to go
down bad and this legend from the
prequels and original trilogy and clone
wars becomes a sad fishmonger who
everyone rose like anakin on beach day
you seem kind of old and beat up the
years have made you weak and the next
nine years are gonna suck even more
uh paz i feel like he he was kind of
trying to speaking of bridging the gap
trying to
turn his voice into alec guinness a
little bit oh yeah yeah i got yay yeah
wasn't he for sure um yeah i think he's
already he's he's doing that a little
bit in the prequels and he's like
maybe increasing it by ten percent here
yeah you know he's closer to alec
dennison like you know he's he's aging
into it yeah i'm gonna jump ahead to a
fan question here because it's kind of
relevant yeah evan j pritz all right the
writer of the canceled kenobi movie said
these episodes were only one part of a
trilogy he envisioned so what would you
like to see if a part two and part three
get made i just want to ask what do you
think happens in the next nine years
that scares him so much that his hair
and be
completely white well i will not take
credit for this joke okay because i did
see this on twitter and i don't remember
who it was so i could credit them
correctly um but someone was like dude
he's like an old white dude on a planet
with two sons and no sunscreen
i mean johnny knoxville went gray while
they were making jackass forever if you
watch jackass 4.5 it's documented that
was less than nine years so at some
point maybe he had to put on like the
the spider helmet
i think that just uh the that tattooing
version of a bull run
and that's all it took yeah um this this
uh speaking of tatooine this
uh series sort of avoids it but it does
continue the streak to a degree of
tatooine being the most interesting
center of the uh center of the far-flung
least important part of the galaxy it'd
be like if everything's centered around
arizona like you could make that show
it's the breaking bad
it's like albuquerque is the only town
in america where things happen i did
like that they got them there
yeah i know i like that i like that we
don't spend this whole show on tattooing
for sure that was a huge relief to me
the moment we left halloween but uh i i
would have to say i know that i i read
the same thing evan uh read about the
writer and he was saying this was the
first part of a trilogy but
i think
i think that's a mistake i think this is
the perfect ending this goes seamlessly
puts you into new hope i don't really
think obi-wan needs to do more between
here and there like i think yeah i like
the note i like the last note of this so
much i'm almost like don't mess with it
this is perfect i hope that like
young luke keeps having uh encounters
with like the sith as he's growing up
and his and beru just has to keep
gaslighting him like yeah yeah that was
just that was just a weird animal
yeah
you didn't see that yeah no just so you
were dreaming that was a weird dream no
we're just playing hide and seek you're
gonna go hide in this little cave uh and
you're gonna seek to find a blaster yeah
i'm gonna go outside
all right let's keep going
prepare for a show that reminds you how
great the prequels were when they're cut
down to a three-minute recap montage and
cheer as the best part of those films
returns
follow along on the celibate religious
man's new mission
stare at a ten-year-old boy all day but
when a special little princess gets
moved to another castle obi will have to
save a skywalker for the up teeth time
even though he's forgotten his super
speed
forgotten how twins work how old are you
and forgotten how to hide like at all
hey uh you gonna change your last name
buddy maybe dye your hair i don't know
stop wearing jedi robes
that's not an improvement you look like
vincent adult man other grown-up it's a
pause i'll just say it one time uh
because this has been my pet fan theory
that i really wish was the case but
we'll have to wait till uh kenobi two
which was that the reason he wasn't
really trying to hide or uh change too
much about his name or his appearance
and live on anakin's home planet and
stuff like that was because he was just
trying to lure darth vader down
he was using luke skywalker as bait he
was a bait boy and he was gonna he was
gonna reva him he's to leap out and just
stab him in the back when he came down
to tatooine
otherwise i have no idea why he's
failing at even the most rudimentary
ways of hiding who you are
as in like not dressing like you know
it's like wearing the face you the cop
uniform of a jedi knight the the organas
they're like a very very well-off family
they're royal they're royal you think
they might worry about like bloodlines
and success
they could they could probably they
could probably adopt two kids like let's
not separate these siblings these twin
siblings and like they're gonna be safer
together and they it bail or gonna
immediately in in sith is like well my
wife and i have always talked about
adopting a daughter he's just like like
luke just gets screwed immediately and
like his sister gets to go live and like
become a princess live in the left
luxury and he's like
farming moisture in the middle of a
desert and the gentleman in like a few
he lives in a field in a dirty field and
he farms moisture this is like the
rawest deal in the galaxy he doesn't
even get to go to tashi station he
doesn't even get to go pick up some
power covers he literally shoots rats
that's his fun that's his hobby
all right let's keep going
thrill at the latest installment of star
wars babies leia edition vivine blair
shines as a young princess with more
sass than carrie fisher if she were
actually born into royalty if anyone
asks you're my daughter granddaughter
maybe
she was great and once this lone wolf
and cub link up you're in for yet
another round of grumpy warrior gets a
cute sassy kid to safety but hey
if
it
ain't
broke
don't
fix
it
hello there again
so many more examples of supporting
characters some of whom don't even live
on tatooine oh
like a guy who puts the mid and
midichlorians so judgmental an imperial
officer who's not like those other
imperials she feels bad about it i
joined up when the empire stood for
something pause i was actually very
impressed with her the the actor and the
and the plotline there just wasn't much
funny about it that i could think of
because she played a big part in the
series um
and i like that she wasn't connected to
some bigger lore
family or or anything that we've heard
of she was just an interesting i think a
better take on like the finn storyline
of the
imperial person with regrets yeah um i
thought that was a better indira varma
so yes there you go thank you
uh she's great yeah and i it was uh it's
it's a role that could have been really
perfunctory but i think she breathed a
lot of like yeah life into it yeah and
they did you know of course they have to
just tease everything for a series or
for i guess and or we'll explore this
but i liked the kind of connection to i
think it's a fun setting to be like the
the rebellions underground railroad of
like shuttling all these people to
safety like that seems like a week to
week like we could do like 24 episodes
of that yeah yeah and i'm sure we we're
about to we're about to well that's yeah
i mean that that's what andor they're
saying it's gonna be it's like his whole
life from childhood through
uh rogue one which means it takes us
through the entire formation of the
rebel alliance so that presumably will
be a bunch of what we see is all the
disparate little groups like the path
coming together and forming like one
yeah
you know creating a base on yeah or
getting all the other stuff set up for
for new hope if it covers that long i
guess she could be in it right she could
be if she could be in the series
young leia no no no oh in deer of armor
yeah oh yeah theoretically i mean i
would say to me like the the most like
like i feel
i feel like uh
kumail and uh ice cube junior are both
in this to pave the way for future
appearances and stuff
yeah you don't just hire camille and ice
cube junior and don't have like a future
plan i mean broken for sure feels like
that this is set up for some other thing
they're going to use but i feel like
they forgot to maybe we're jumping ahead
here but i feel like they forgot to set
him up they tell us he's really cool
he doesn't do anything he doesn't get
much they say like people believe in you
because you're their leader and we don't
really did i miss that part well i mean
we see him like he
he
he is like we gotta open this door right
right he's the nominal leader like he
makes a few announcements like he's
there to be the the leader of that group
in those scenes that's his role in those
scenes but no there isn't a moment to
give him like he doesn't get like a hero
moment and he should and and my feeling
is
because this isn't like the reason his
character exists is not this story it's
the next one because they do have that
moment where he's like my series coming
financial q3 yeah 2025 i mean it is
basically like you get ready for more
broken kids because
he's coming back all right keep going
i made some mistakes and evil twisted
villains like modern star wars fandom if
you're sending her bullying messages
you're no star wars fan in my mind riva
a youngling who never finished her
grooming but graduated with honors from
the loud quiet london school of villainy
tell me where the jedi is what makes you
think
he won't see it coming send out the
probes do it nobody's coming
you can't find obi-wan and he
slaughtered them
that's um i almost called it the eddie
redmayne school of loud quiet loud
family but i just don't think enough
people saw jupiter ascending but please
treat yourself yeah as eddie redmayne
has only gone on to bigger and better
things it's really fun to bigger things
bigger things it's definitely
i don't know i i i would much rather
watch jupiter ascending again than any
of them be smooth a thousand percent i
would i would watch jupiter sending
twice because the thing about the thing
about there's more beasts in jupiter oh
there's way more oh there's way it's not
even close
it's not even close there's way more
beasts and they're doing way more
fantastic things in jupiter ascending
but the other thing to note about eddie
redmayne is he's not just doing quiet
loud quiet acting he's doing it's the
weirdest voice he's using an accent that
literally is from space like it's never
been used on earth no it's a different
atmosphere really remarkable stuff
definitely give that a re-watch i should
re-watch you personally oh my god they
should all rewatch it's bananas like if
we were gonna do twitch watch alongs i
think that's one of the movies we could
count it all right throw into the book
maybe we can get an abraxas to join to
skype in what else are they doing what
else are they doing
um also i do i desperately need to know
who's doing the cornrows in the empire
okay um i want to know how those came to
be i want to know who you guys there's a
droid there's a droid
there's a joy that just lowers onto the
head
and just sits there and gossip with you
and then i talked to seven
thirty and he was like nah girl and i
was like what and then seven ten
thirties baby seven ten forty eighty
ninety came in and his baby daddy they
are still fighting
oh here comes that beat and then it's
like
america
this is i think we've come up with the
next spit on the droid barbershop well i
mean the droid barbershop beauty shop
spin-off is one of my favorite star wars
uh ancillary content things is droids
the cartoons yes yes um just because of
the stewart culture but i mean you get
humans are the clients it's the droids
are the the beauticians in the barber so
it's like in treatment
yeah you're right you're just we're just
yeah it's like lebron james and maverick
carter are there
destroyed
oh done
just talking about droid problems
you know it's a mix it's a mix of
whatever's going on in the world you
know i feel pain uh
droid rights check literally a mix of
man and machine hayden christensen kills
it in a dual role as both the guy in the
big d suit and his anakin in his seventh
senior year at jedi academy he'll give
us fresh insight into vader's loss of
humanity and show us what really turned
annie to the dark side you'll need to
prove yourself as your undoing until you
overcome it apparently so to prove
himself worthy of being a jedi anakin
had to try his hardest to stop trying so
hard to prove himself worthy of being a
jedi okay this scene makes sense now
so pause i think it was a a great team
effort i wish this was like you know
people want um what's his name andy
circus to get an oscar for you know
something like this but i think that you
should give some not an emmy but like
a fanny a fan award to uh to hayden to
the group of hayden christensen the
de-aging tech darth vader uh or james
earl jones and the uh weird artificial
intelligence that fixed his voice
because i think they managed to unite
you know the tuna fish and peanut butter
together something that wasn't as weird
as it should have been there's no way
hayden christian was in that suit the
whole time he was was he the whole time
i don't know every shot i feel like some
of those vader scenes there's like a guy
in that she talked about bulking up for
it oh well there you go but he can't
grow
six seven inches or yeah david prowse is
like a bodybuilder right that's what i'm
saying like they they must have found a
guy who matched prowse's stature that
was hayden maybe maybe in lyft's i don't
know
maybe um well because i know like in
mandalorian obviously that was not not
yeah most of those scenes so i i assumed
that it was a body double yeah but it's
also definitely wearing the suit
certainly in the scenes well and this is
where his yeah helmet these his face is
parked i don't know someone fact-checked
me on this i thought he was actually for
the most part the guy in the suit
honestly like that
wouldn't surprise me i mean they could
have put them in some kind of lifts or
something to make them look bigger
because i was noticing it because
they're kind of shooting him from far
away a lot
of people can't really see he you don't
have those scenes where he's just like
staring down and right officer or
something i could see hayden christensen
like
going the extra mile to be yeah no but
even though they could like in the darth
vaders they could have done the tom
cruise trick of like cut a little trench
in the set for ewan to walk in so that
his co-star so just like
yeah i mean that is like they do that on
some tom cruise movies like far and away
there are scenes where he's walking in a
little trench so that nicole kidman
doesn't tower over him because she's
taller than him
more more on that in a future video it's
true that's true that's a true fact all
right keep playing little trench
so enjoy the weird new middle ground of
star wars that looks bad for a movie but
good for a tv show too short for a
series but too long for a film
incredible lightsaber duels but rinky
dink said
and his story comes by the truth that
was just funny that's it but i do think
that they uh especially that lightsaber
duel to me was them making the most of a
mid budget i don't know it's so hard to
say anymore how much money anything
should be i'm curious like i
legitimately don't know the answer to
this but i'm curious as to whether it's
more a time crunch or a financial budget
i mean it's obviously both on something
disney does not like spending money it's
obviously both but i'm i'm curious as to
which one is more breathing down their
necks i feel like it could be a time
crunch like these are on such a
crazily set schedule and it's very
ambitious and i do wonder if sometimes
there's just like we got to make our
days and if it's like it looks as good
as it is it's going to look and then we
got to move on to the next set up for
the biggest franchise you know uh
segment to marvel and dc but right but
those are i guess you could look at it
as like well those are the two choices
it's crank out a ton of these shows but
like
you got to make your days or do a lot
fewer shows and films but
lavish them with more time and i think
that's that's sometimes that's a good
thing is that they don't have the uh
infinite budget because for me i've
appreciated the lightsaber fights in
this one more than the prequels where
it's just a
endless 20-minute long flip session of
just flipping and poking flipping and
poking well that's right because lucas
had like those were basically big indie
films he was making them himself and he
could decide how big it got so it's like
opposite in some ways almost this is the
this is the corporate constrained vision
and that's the like art guy going for it
yeah exactly um all right keep playing
geez that take place before and after
but drops enough breadcrumbs to launch a
rogue squadron's worth of future star
wars content
just getting started i think i had a
brother i think i've just found out what
they're hiding down here okay none of
those jedi are actually dead disney just
jurassic park them until it's their turn
for a show
can what explain that to me because they
were it's like full taxidermy because
you got to assume
they the sift didn't use or the
inquisitors didn't use some kind of like
freeze ray like kill them with a
lightsaber or a blast or something and
then recreate it put them back in the
pose of their death because they're like
they're frozen in there yeah i'm not i
hm
i are they dead i i assumed that they
were dead okay i'm assuming that's like
some sort of like formaldehyde like yeah
just like the the snoke jars like
whatever whatever liquid snoke is
floating in in his snoke jar liquid
snoke is what i used to make
those are those are just history snoke
jars but i do i mean i'm i'm joking
about the snow chairs but i do think
that they are trying to create like a
little like a line between like this is
the dark science cloning secrets only
the sith knew
gotcha
i'm guessing that that's not i don't
know if that's canada but to me i think
they're they're kind of setting up the
history of like dark imperial science
yeah and so this is like the this is the
beginning of the technology that will
eventually lead to them cloning
palpatine okay and like they're this is
like they're trying to figure out like
can we isolate like what makes you
midichlorians or like what gives you
force powers or like how would we bring
you know whatever
this is where we need the um the lucas
uh sequel he wanted to make that takes
place on the microscopic level like the
osmosis yeah yeah yeah this is right
i didn't and then you brought it back
osmosis jones but now that's gonna be
there all day now that's mostly
skywalker all right let's keep playing
all day
boring
gentle ben
problem child
that's what i love about these
younglings man i get older they stay the
same age
neon genesis revangelian i don't like
sand snakes they're coarse and rough and
irritating he doesn't even go here
hashtag justice for hat
we only sell moisture here where the
jedi round back
oh my beiru what i got i gotta give it
to ariva
well none jedi
nice cube
and the one lesson disney can't afford
to learn it's the past move on be done
with it ben
bravo thank you
so riva's plan was to work her way up to
grand inquisitor then just try to stab
darth vader in the back
probably gonna see that one coming it's
literally the only way sith get promoted
yeah so we didn't really dive into walk
up item and uh you know stab him
good plan good plan we didn't really get
into riva's plan
or it's shifting plan but
once that fails and she doesn't stab
darth vader in the back can you explain
me why she then goes to kill luke
skywalker as revenge for what who
for the young legs uh youngling for a
lady a young thing for a young one yeah
yeah well i think you you could for
young you could read it as revenge
against
ben like obi-wan
like she knows he's protecting this
child and so she's gonna kill the child
he's protecting as revenge for all the
kids that cause anakin didn't know luke
existed if it was like i'm gonna kill
your most precious but i do i do think
there you could i
i you could also retroactively say she
figures out that this is anakin's kid
she's gonna go kill him and then she's
gonna tell anakin because she does love
to do that like a villain speech right
you've seen her go like oh you didn't
know anakin was darth vader
she loves to be the one that gets to
tell you the tragic news so i do feel
like she might have wanted to kill luke
and then go back and be like you had a
son but you don't know
me i win
that could have worked out
theoretically but i i would i would say
as well none of that is in the show some
of that should have been in the show all
of that is me
adding things to the show
maybe i'm just like a weakling but i
thought that it was funny uh that she
gets worked so hard by darth vader and
doesn't just like like i quit like
she gets so wrecked by him he throws her
uh her own lightsaber back he's like
come back up come get me that isn't one
of the coolest things that was amazing
that is pretty come on yeah that is
pretty just to be like oh no no here we
go you dropped something yeah
okay now come back i would i would quit
i would never play uh lightsaber again
and then similarly with darth vader when
he gets put in a hole you know seven
leagues deep under the under the sea
obi-wan gets the permanent high ground
on him yeah and this is like an old out
of practice man that had not picked up a
lightsaber in a couple years and you
know i just quit
anakin should have just stopped right
there like i guess i just don't have
that it factor one of these one of these
epic lightsaber deals should just end
with somebody being like
screw it yeah she's like rage quitting
that's going to be camille in one of the
next things
like you know i i'm not up to this i get
it you're you're you know what you're
right you're right i guess it's just
fate uh all right let's keep playing or
was that it that was it
i guess that's obi-wan and new hope
where he's like ah forget it you know
what screw this
outtakes
iron chef juan kenobi
gone girl
the princess inquiries so it's canon
that adult leia dresses like a
ten-year-old
yes let the hate flow
say hey
again it's back again
took her licks from order 66 snake emoji
sung kang wins
pharma bro
joey sucks
i thought droid sucks
for vendetta
cute thank you
all right
um well this has been fun uh we are
doing other things besides this show we
do other things other things so like and
subscribe and you can watch the uh we're
doing a ms marvel episode three and four
review which is going very well i'm
liking that show um
and apparently it's going to be from at
home because the gamers are using the
studio speaking of the gamers check out
um twitch.tv backslash fandom check out
our phantom twitch channel we will start
doing movie stuff on there soon but hey
if you like video games too good times
um on to your questions we've got
morbius g fuel to finish so we gotta get
back here
sometime soon don't tempt me uh langley
emilia s after redeeming hayden
christensen is it possible for star wars
to redeem jar jar binks and his actor he
got screwed more than anyone in the
prequels yeah i'm at best i'm the best
let's bring him back i i feel like you
really could bring jar jar back and the
fans would embrace him now if you did it
right what if they did that really sad
thing the way he ended in the book
there's like a street jester yeah
oh it's really it's a bummer it's super
bummer town it's in one of the books
where they're just like there's a clown
who plays for all the kids every day and
he's sad and everyone hates him but he's
so happy that he gets to make the kids
laugh and he's basically like oops mia
make a mistake
he's like hanging out but the doctor i
am a joker
i am a jar jar okay that's that's all
right sold yeah i want to see did you
guys see that i put it in the the slack
yesterday uh there's a guy who edited it
jar jar into qui-gon's place at the end
of kenobi if you have not seen it i
believe uh jesse mclaren on twitter
that's right look it up great like it's
me
um daryl acevedo asks are there still
hidden allen raptors in all the honest
trailers and you know what there aren't
no they haven't been for a while and i
am furious and i think that kevin needs
to put them back in oh my god that's
instant
raptor opportunity yeah oh we've got
some good raptor opportunities
didn't
well there was that but it came back it
got a it got unsnapped
and there were i i just started trusting
him to just put a raptor in so i just
assumed that there was and everyone but
no there haven't been raptors lately no
i
want them back okay we'll get back we'll
get back to heidi i mean that's kevin
he's our editor and except for randy is
filling in as kevin moves and he did a
great job this week um but as soon as
kevin's back i expect we'll start maybe
two the race
the return of the allen raptor uh
all right so um benzy10 has to let's
talk about other movies do the rocks
from everything everywhere all at once
deserve an oscar nomination such solid
performances i thought there was some
good uh rock work in obi-wan kenobi um
when obi brought up all those rocks
behind him oh yeah oh yeah
he got buried by rocks and then he was
like no i'm not buried by rocks and then
he's like boom rocks yeah his big like
goku moment
charging up yeah it's gonna be a it's
gonna be a tough category for rock of
the year um greenstar asks what's that
queen's shadow book behind lawn
ooh is that a novelization of uh it's
about padme padme uh amidala it looks
like
sweet
well take it home with you tell us give
us a full book report next week
yeah it's uh it's it's about padme as
she steps down as queen and becomes uh
the naboo's next representative in the
galactic senate yeah sweet
required reading it survived
nice yeah i still 100 didn't understand
the government in a booth and i am okay
you get elected to be the queen what
does it make sense about that
um that's what queen means we'll end
with this johanna stromer asks what
movie pitch would work best with the in
space tag for example ace ventura in
space uh can i pick that one i want it
yeah i wanted
space that one works pretty well
god forbid fantastic beast should go to
space i mean
i think we already got there it's more
morbius in space
i was going to say 500 days of summer in
space except they're actually just on a
sun planet
it's always summer
good times well uh some other good
questions in here that we'll add
we'll get to with next week's honest
trailer we'll talk about kenobi some
more but no we won't uh we will be
talking about a
uh
something that does travel throughout
space and maybe time um but you've
probably been there before that's your
clue for next week uh we had a good time
didn't you i had fun
always a good time we'll see you then
thank you so much for watching australia
commentaries bye-bye
[Music]
you